as you all know magnus carlsen is having
one of the worst tournament of life
he's playing the norway championship and
he still without a win and she's sharing
last place he was two games won against
the eleven aragon and yesterday won
against the Vladimir Kramnik with two
more rounds to go
things aren't looking very good for the
world champion so here is a gameplay not
so long ago it was played in the double
masters last year in 2016
and cotton was the first round to kick
our Nakamura and then she want to round
and this is run for the Bluebell Masters
where he is playing the Filipino
Grandmaster weapon so so let's see the
game Coughlin is playing white and what
we saw is black crossed and opened with
e4 e5 Knight f3 knight c6 and Bishop b5
the real opus and here the standard
mover was from black to play a six which
is a move play for almost more than 300
years but the Wesley so plays Knight to
f6 this is the Berlin defence this
became popular after the match Kasparov
versus Kramnik in 2000 where chronic one
and I think in all the games to this
variation was played coffin goes to d3
Bishop to c5 and now Carlson takes on c6
he wants to mess up like bone structure
and although you should to usually take
towards the center here
he takes c6 hit play and Carson loves
these kinds of positions as he's a
master maneuver he's really good with
the nice and
something like carpool was in his days
or kappa blanka a long time ago so
Carson plays Queen TV - still not sure
what if he's going to cast for Queen
side or King side
Wesley does the same thing and Carson
goes night to d2 already you can see he
doesn't devote his Knight to c3 because
from c3 he doesn't really have anywhere
else to go now or in any distant future
but here he has a lot of ideas you can
go to c4 than III the net 5 or you can
go to even f1 and g3 or f1 and e3 and
when Wesley plays Bishop to g4 cousin
plays h3 Bishop to h5 a3 nice to d7
I'm here coffin rep some space v4 when
you place Bishop to b6 and now Knight c4
and already we can see this knife is the
position nicely he has a nice square was
it plays f6 and now maneuvering the
night over - III find that f5 square
what we can't really play g6 because
that will mess up his King sights too
much and he careful twin size or well
the position of loconut addictive as
those a and B pawns are already of the
board so what he tries to get some time
to play with a pipe and here Carson
finally gets his Knight to f5 where to
place Queen to f8 and our cross and
opens up the position B takes a5 rook
takes a 5 and call some castles getting
his King to safety
whether plays Queen to f7 and now
caution goes a for grabbing some more
space on the Queen side and preparing to
develop his vision and here where the so
should probably has castles but it plays
Knight to c5 and here there is a number
of things you can do if you can move it
is like the EC
than two before or you can simply take
the pawn on f4 but here is the move or
weight limit and this is a beautiful
move by house and although it's a simple
law it's a very subtle move Queen to a
queen te one I'm pinning the Queen from
the bishop on h5 and also attacking the
rook on a5 and hear what he plays b6
protecting the rook and now nice to be
to unpinning the knight from the bishop
so the bishop can capture it and here
Wesley probably still should look for
Castle but his entire game strategy so
far was the read the a four point so
weakly if you give that up well she just
worse so what we graduate route to a
four and here is another beautiful move
by constantly wise we missed nice to see
four and although it seems like the
cotton is given up a broken a one drug
cannot be taken as if it black takes the
rook then simply Knight to d6 pinning
the Queen and King after the knight is
taken another nice will capture it and
black loses his queen so after 94 black
cancer capture the rook so instead he
plays Bishop let's say it's a rather
ugly move but there's nothing better to
play and here across from just develops
Bishop to e3 attacking the knight and
also protecting the rook with the Queen
King to d7 and already you can see how
white pieces are placed and the public
pieces are plays the rook on h8 is doing
nothing the bishop is a net face
blocking the rook the queen is on f7 the
bishop is on h5 cotton goes cool to c3
and now what we find the move that isn't
very good he plays nice to e4
of course this person takes the knight
then you know the Queen will take the
white knight on c4 but Carson just
captures and be
six with check first after Cece takes b6
now recaptures the piece and opens up
the line for the rook putting to sea for
what is desperately trying to exchange
wings but our son of course isn't
interested in that Queen to d2 check
Kimi to c7m now g4 blocking the bishops
of the route can go to be one Bishop to
g6 and the simple rook F to be one and
what we so resign doesn't really matter
what what we play into Queen to d7 of
being the d8 is an unstoppable mate for
example I don't know is the route is
taken simply put the s7 or no even
better Queen to d8 wherever the king
goes the pinwheels capture and after the
king goes here till this is completely
winning so yeah this was the game played
not so long ago and our cars Carlton was
very much unstoppable so it's hard to
say what's the problem in Norway is his
new girlfriend is it his new hair it's
really hard to say he has two more
rounds to save the results he's been
having so far I think if he if he
doesn't lose both of his both of his
games that he should still be okay and
maybe he will remain role number one for
now so yeah this is the game I hope you
enjoyed it and see you soon